first time ever the AFC championship
game will be played in Kansas City
Patriots have two chiefs Patriots
they're eight straight years but they
they have not won a road playoff game
since they upended the Chargers the
fourteen and two Chargers in 2006 guys
I'll tell you what that this one I could
go either way and we could talk about
this up until kickoff and never really
figure out how it's gonna go because I'd
say these teams are evenly matched we
saw a classic regular-season game
between them and as soon as that game
ended in week six 43 to 40 we thought
hey let's have the rematch let's play
the rematch now in the postseason and
unlike last year when we didn't get the
Steelers Patriots rematch in the
postseason we're getting this one uh you
know this is gonna be a great game I
thing I'm looking at for this game
Patrick Moore Holmes even last week I
thought he missed some throws I thought
he wasn't as sharp as he had been in the
regular season yeah and there's been a
few times where he's been in big games
even a game where he won like the Monday
night game where they went to Denver
right and he missed a few throws and he
wasn't as sharp this is his first time
in this situation this big of a stage
and I think the Chiefs with how their
defense has played all year they need
Patrick Holmes to basically be perfect
yeah I mean I I don't disagree with that
my Holmes is going to have to play
certainly better than he did the first
time around okay and you know it's a big
cats point you know a guy like me who
watches film and all that he does leave
a number of throws on the field every
week that's what's amazing because you
go and you go wow he threw for 400 yards
but he probably should have thrown for
500 or something like that
last week he didn't miss a few throws I
know the ones you're talking about down
the middle ball came out of his hand
funny Tyree kill was open a few times
there but yes he cannot repeat some of
the mistakes we saw in that first
matchup throwing interception in the
game right Mike we saw that throwing
interceptions in the red zone if they do
those type of things they're gonna lose
this football game there's no doubt
about that because you can't depend on
Brady and Belichick turning it over and
screwing up situational football and in
that game week six Sunday Night Football
that was his first really big moment was
and I think that it overwhelmed him in
the first half we saw him putting too
much air under the football and then in
the second half he completed that pass
he rolled to the right we showed that
yesterday broke it down where he rolls
to the right he finds Karim hunt for the
touchdown that the
changes the feel of the game and you
could see how excited he was after that
because now they're gonna make it a game
and now he's settled down and this stage
isn't too big for man we've seen him
play well on a big stage all throughout
the year since that Patriots game but
what happens he plays well and the
Chiefs lose we saw it against the Rams
in the 54-51 game we saw it against the
Chargers in that epoch Thursday night
game we saw it against the Seahawks week
16 Sunday night
the only time he delivered on a big
stage was last Saturday afternoon and I
think that that that's more of an
indictment to the people around him but
but at some point you know whether
you're Peyton Manning Tom Brady whoever
you you are stuck with the teammates
that you have and you have to rise above
that whatever the circumstance you've
got to find a way to make the play at
the right time to deliver the victory
and I think that's on Patrick mahomes
the defense at some point is going to
let him down he's gonna be the one who
has to pick the team up and carry it he
may not be ready to do it in only a
second season this may be something that
happens here three year four year five
but I think that's gonna be the
difference when he can be the one to
deliver victory when his teammates may
not be in the right mode to do so so the
other big thing for this game and I'll
ask Chris this because I'm very curious
the the first game you talked about the
first game against the Patriots on
Sunday Night Football game yeah Kareem
Han had a huge game right he was you
know the pagers had no answer for yeah
running and catching yeah right so
condemning Williams be that same guy
because it seems like the whole Chiefs
offense sort of goes off that because
Travis Kelce he's gonna get open if
Damian Williams is it can can be a
threat I think that he can be I think
the big thing there Inman adding to that
fact is just Andy Reid also being
patient with the run like if Andy Reid
if they get into all we're gonna throw
the ball 50 times this game they're
going to lose there's no doubt about you
can't be one-dimensional against Bill
Belichick Brian Flores and company I do
think we've seen them kind of be a
little bit more balanced lately to
answer your question with giving Damian
Williams the ball we've seen them throw
them a lot of screen passes he certainly
will be a big factor in the game and
let's be honest this team is an
offensive football team right that's how
they're built they're built to win
shootouts and put the pressure on you
that way they missed that opportunity in
the first game the first game you know
they made a stop on the first drive of
the game against the New England
Patriots offense they got the ball back
I believe one up two
nothing but miss like you talked about
already Mike mahomes was off early he
missed some wide-open throws that we had
not seen him miss and you just can't
afford to leave those opportunities on
the field in a game like this where you
know especially if Kansas City can jump
out early that will really play in their
favor if this gets to the end of the
first quarter and it's like seven three
or ten seven I would say uh-oh this is a
New England type of football game and
they might be in trouble
Patrick mahomes in the first half of the
regular season match between the
Patriots and the Chiefs 14 of 23 164
yards no touchdown passes two
interceptions the Donte Hightower they
they duped
mahomes into throwing the ball and
Hightower jumped up and got it and then
that ball in the end zone that was a bad
throw but he did have incompletions that
were just ugly first half second half
nine of 13 for 188 yards and four
touchdowns with no picks a different guy
in the second half of that game and
they're gonna be looking to bring that
second-half vibe into the first half
look at what they did to the Colts last
week up 14 nothing and it felt like it
was over from that point they're going
to want to try to deliver an early
knockout and then hold on if they can
one thing about this game too that when
the week began we were talking about and
we haven't had to mention it because it
hasn't been an issue he had that moment
on Saturday where we thought he was hurt
we thought the need was messed up he was
walking on it funny he was on the
sideline he didn't want the trainer
coming over to look at it he didn't even
want to acknowledge he may be injured he
has not been on the injury report he is
good to go he is fine that is not going
to be a factor we got a fully and
completely 100% mahomes by all
appearances a 100% Tom Brady so both
guys fully healthy but for a while last
Saturday it looked like there may be a
real concern about mahomes ability to be
mahomes this week the other health thing
that I look at in this game no onesie
really talking about the fact that
Julian Edelman is finally a hundred
percent healthy ready to go eyeing his
best football that to me is more
important than I know there's been a lot
of talk about Brady he's getting older
I've been part of it Gronk
Gragas gragas clearly obviously not the
same player he was four or five years
ago but Edelman seems to be back in full
form and that's a total game changer
because obviously Tom Brady knows he can
throw it to him it and
time yeah I mean they're they're great
at designing place for him in and I
agree with you that he is a you know I
think you know it's that time of the
year where he's finally got over that
ACL injury right it's it's usually year
two they say or maybe eighteen months
somewhere in that timeframe and he does
look quicker and more explosive right
now so he has become a weapon especially
off that play-action pass that we talked
about in the first hour I think you know
what I want to go back to one thing
about Kansas City that I think is
extremely important for this football
game first of all it is great that my
homes in Kansas City are getting to play
the Patriots again because the Patriots
ran some defenses in that game as a
young quarterback Huma Holmes is really
you know a rookie that's in a second
year he saw defenses that he hadn't seen
to up to that point so I don't think
he'll be caught off guard by it this
time around the other thing that I we
really I think have to focus in on can
the Patriots keep him in the pocket cuz
as we watch Kansas City every week when
Patrick mahomes gets out of side of the
pocket we always we stand up out of our
seats cuz we go oh here it comes it's
gonna be sidearm or laser across the
field and he makes more big plays
outside of the pocket than any other
quarterback in football if they can keep
him in the pocket can Patrick mahomes
dissect them that way that will be a big
question mark for me and I would almost
say no because we haven't seen him just
truly stay in the pocket all game long
and be that surgical guy like a Brady
Aubrey's Ken and I would think that
would be something New England to focus
on and Patrick mahomes getting outside
the pocket I mean I think you'd agree
Chris that the Chiefs man-for-man have
more talent yes than the Patriots yes
so the Patriots might have a better
scheme they have better coaching but
when things break down irie Kilwa you're
not having to guard these exactly right
yeah I feel the same way and here's the
thing about mahomes and trying to keep
him in the pocket I mean they can say
hey they want to try to keep him in the
pocket but he's got that athleticism
that just kind of he just explodes on
you and even if you're doing everything
you can ultimately you're talking about
defensive ends and linebackers who are
trying to keep a guy in the pocket and
he can run circles around them it's like
hey fine sorry I'm getting out of the
pocket no matter what you do to try to
keep me in here and and I think that's
gonna be the challenge and and he knows
that it's almost like a Ben
Roethlisberger trait where moving
laterally he almost throws better than
when he's standing still and and he'll
escape that he's good enough that it
doesn't matter
yeah and I think that that's something
the Patriots may just have to accept and
I think across the board both teams you
have to acknowledge the other team is
gonna score points right that there are
going to be moments where you feel like
it's not going your way and you can't
stop them and you just have to accept
that and we talked earlier about it how
many times will the Chiefs have to stop
the Patriots and the other side of the
coin how many times will the Patriots
have to stop the Chiefs and that's what
it's gonna come down so I'm gonna use
that tennis analogy again who can break
serve once that may be all it takes to
win the game why would you bring tennis
into this I don't know I couldn't think
of any other sport that I could make it
better still football season three games
there behind tennis there playing tennis
in Australia I think he got season
there's so many interesting matchups
across the board I mean how much does
Stephon Gilmore gonna match up with
Tyree kill what are the Patriots gonna
do to take Travis Kelce away in certain
situations I think speaking to the
pocket thing with my home's you know
okay let him go out of the pocket but
make sure he goes left I think that's
one thing we'd saw the Patriots try to
do even in the interception in the end
zone
Donte Hightower in the first matchup he
was dragging on the homes as he was
throwing they were ready for him to you
know go to the right so so that will be
certainly a big aspect and then we look
at New England on the other side of the
ball I mean come on can Kansas City make
some stops and I think that's the big
question because they have it in any big
moments really all year long yeah this
is gonna be the don't overthink it pic
of the week though III mean the Patriots
are like you are you gonna feel so
you're gonna feel stupid if you picked
the Chiefs in this game you are right he
is stupid did I pick the Chargers yeah
the key to all these games is yeah you
want to win but more than anything you
don't want to look stupid
you can't look stupid if you pick the
Patriots because if something goes wow
they're the underdogs they can't win
games I mean I don't think I still
haven't found more than a few people who
have said the Patriots suck but I do I
appreciate any time an athlete has to
find motivation anywhere I mean Julian
Edelman he posts like six different hype
videos
every single week and I know it gets him
excited and why not yeah I have seen so
many arguments on social media between
Chiefs fans and Patriots fans over which
team is really the underdog I mean the
reality is neither team is because the
three-point spreads a result of the game
being played in Kansas City neutral site
this is a victim game okay I like it
there Mike
put him in we go you'd literally there
is one underdog in one favorite yeah I
know but they both want to be the
underdog they both want that motivation
they both want to thank everyone doubts
them and it's amazing to think that
grown men need that but just by virtue
of what's unfolded this week there's all
the proof we need yeah that they do need
they'll take anything they can get to
get the extra motivation behind things
to hate the other team every week and
you know of course I wasn't that great
my career wasn't that great but that's
what you do as an athlete give me the
best thing you ever did to get yourself
motive I mean I would always just look
at the other quarterback a lot of times
they'd be like man I'm better than him
this guy but that's really where I went
and I want to be like I'm gonna show
that I'm the best one on the field this
week or you know I woke up one day and
I'm watching a pregame show and Mike
Ditka said I had the most pressure on me
on a Sunday you know and I'm like damn I
didn't know I had the pressure on me I
just I thought about him and just before
the game like I'm gonna prove his butt
wrong today and go out there and have a
good day and actually did have a good
day that day what were your numbers that
day I don't know that was the day where
we ended up going for two with Mike
Alstott over the top against the
Redskins where we just got in and won a
36 35 thriller how can you remember all
those details and not remember what your
stat line was that day very good it was
very good I know that I know everybody
else's stat line better than I knew my
own eye I just answered the question who
did you play that day Washington
Redskins and Greg Williams I had my way
with them that way here Year 2005
regular season yes so check it out
they're out yeah all right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports